will you pray with me
Oh God may the words of my mouth and the
meditation of each of our hearts be
pleasing in your sight Oh God a rock and
our Redeemer amen I once heard a woman
described herself as an EQ maniac she
loved acumen ism she clung so strongly
to the hope that Christians of different
ecumenical denominations could finally
one day focus on the common ground they
shared instead of the places of conflict
this woman never quite found a single
denomination that she was willing to
call home because for her saying yes to
one meant saying no to all the rest and
she wasn't ready to do that she was not
shy about calling herself in a coup
maniac so passionate was her desire for
Christian unity I will never forget that
conversation some 10 years ago we had
this conversation at the very time I was
discerning a call to Divinity School
into ordained ministry a process that
asks you to identify what you are I was
a relatively new Lutheran knowing all
too well that choosing one denomination
meant I was no longer officially a
member of another even in an ecumenical
Divinity School I was asked what
denomination are you far more than I was
ever asked what do you think of
Christian unity could I be both Lutheran
and Anna cumin 'used if you have
traveled to another country you may have
felt this same tension when we come from
one place and travel to another it's
important to notice our expectations do
we expect things to be exactly the same
as in our homeland probably not do we
expect to fit in immediately no but we
do eagerly look for those footholds
anything that looks familiar someone who
can
speak a little bit of our language and
help us get some dinner can one belong
to a single denomination and be fully
committed to humanism and Christian
unity can we you be both from a
particular country or place and be
globally minded today along with other
Christians around the globe we celebrate
world communion sunday our liturgical
assistant ali who is traveling today
quickly noticed from all of the buzz
around this day that this is one of the
university church's most important feast
days we have claimed it and we put a lot
of energy and love into this day what
most people remember about world
communion sunday i would guess is that
we offer many different kinds of bread
during our holy communion or bari from
iran thank you mourad gingerbread from
carol Conroy's kitchen rice cakes from
southeast asia brought by shell nine
different kinds of bread from all around
the world will be for us today christ's
body and blood what I hope we remember
besides how wonderful the cornbread or
the non tastes this morning is that
Christians around the world celebrate
this sacrament using the staple breads
of their local communities maybe today's
feast with nine breads will linger with
us a little longer than just today maybe
this memory will come with us back to
church two weeks from now for Holy
Communion again when we take a piece of
our wonderful rich you see why communion
bread a recipe Ian brought and remember
that this is about one kind of bread
that Christians around the world used to
remember the meal on the night in which
Jesus was betrayed we just sang those
wonderful words from Psalm 133 behold
how good
and how pleasant it is for kindred to
dwell together in unity but let's be
honest sharing bread from another
culture is not the definition of unity
though it is fun singing songs from
Haiti or Zimbabwe this morning does not
fully unite us with those living amid
earthquake rubble or in a country
ravaged by hiv/aids sure in our
communion bread in our global songs we
are on our way to unity but we are not
there yet when Christians in Iran are
imprisoned because of their faith yet
many of us take our religious liberties
for granted we are not there yet when
Christians with in denominations battle
over doctrine and those tensions become
the focus instead of Christ call to work
for justice we are not there yet when
Christians define who is a real believer
and who's a fake and forget that in
Christ we are one family we are not
there yet how good and how pleasant it
is when kindred when Christian sisters
and brothers on every continent live
together in unity and we are not there
yet world communion sunday should not
just be a celebration of the gifts of
many cultures it is also a day that
calls us to humility patience repentance
deep listening Paul's letter to the
Ephesians which we heard in Farsi this
morning and read in English has an
urgent tone I beg you to lead a life
worthy of the calling to which you were
called central concern for Paul or one
of his disciples that may have penned
this letter in his name we don't know a
central concern is unity Paul calls his
church members of the household of God
and he continues to use the imagery of
the body knit together by every ligament
to describe the church
Paul begs us to live a life worthy of
the calling to which we have been called
unity are we worthy of this calling how
are we doing when it comes to global
global and local Christian unity a
couple of years ago in his New York
Times column Peter Steinfeld's asked has
the movement for unity among Christians
gone into a coma out our Christians
worthy of the calling to unite with each
other and Christ that calling so urgent
for Paul maybe were not so worthy but if
the church gave up every time it wasn't
living up to the calling of God we would
be in an even bigger mess than we
already are if as individuals we gave up
every time we weren't following Christ
examples perfectly we would also be in
trouble and so we trust that our God is
a God of second chances of third and
fourth and fifth and ten thousandth
chances so what might we do to be worthy
of that calling to live in unity with
other Christians and now I realize I've
interrupted the Apostle Paul sentence
earlier so I'll let him carry on I
therefore the prisoner of the lord beg
you to lead a life worthy of the calling
to which you have been called with all
humility and gentleness with patience
bearing with one another in love making
every effort to maintain the unity of
the Spirit in the bond of peace maybe it
is not our task to create Christian
unity maybe instead our calling is to be
humble and patient and loving toward
other Christians at face value this
sounds like a much less glamorous
project to be humble and patient and
loving that it is to create Christian
unity
but if we have been trying to create
Christian unity it means we have
forgotten that we already have Christian
unity unity is a gift from God from that
first birth date of the church when the
tongues of fire and the Holy Spirit
stirred up something in this newborn
church and gave all the ability to
understand one another though they were
speaking different languages Christian
unity is a gift from God in Baptism when
we are united with Christ not because we
are worthy of this but because God has
already made it so is it really up to us
to create a bond between our church and
other churches well I sure hope not we
know all too well how interest in
dialogue is going or sometimes not going
these days it is up to us to remember
and celebrate the unity that already
exists between us and God and between us
and other Christian communities we can't
make God love us God just loves us we
can't make Jesus forgive us Jesus has
already fully forgiven us and we can't
make the diverse Christian community
around the world into one Church
Universal God's Spirit has already knit
us together like it or not if this is
true and i believe it is then today is
about remembering this unity remembering
that our church is just as united with
Christ as another church with whom we
may disagree and this calls on our
deepest humility remembering that our
church is united in churches in war-torn
nations and this calls for our most
gentle prayers and fierce advocacy
remembering that we are united with
those we who with whom we do not yet
know or understand
and this calls for more patience than we
normally bring with us to church but God
has made us worthy of this calling to
which we have been called a calling to
be united with Christ and other
Christians and by God's grace and the
power of the Holy Spirit and through the
taste of breads from around the world
and a drink from the cup of blessing we
have a foretaste of what that unity
might look like a unity that says all
are welcome a unity that with the
prophet Isaiah calls us to beat our
swords into plowshares our spears into
pruning hooks a unity that is so
desperately needed in the world and each
of our lives so I hope you'll join me in
praying that this may be so amen